this is part two of a video about two
candles in a cake i imagine it will make
more sense if you've seen part one so
check out those links
real cakes
are not linear unless they're battenberg
cakes and i only got battenberg the
linear thing and there's a tradition of
mathematical puzzles with battenberg
cakes but anyway real cakes look more
like this this is a nice lemon drizzle i
appreciate your choice um we did by the
way everyone we did buy a bettenberg we
did buy a batten
we're not using this one we'll solve
some other mathematical puzzles with
that one or just eat it yeah
all right
i wanted to upgrade because the like the
original puzzle with twix and you don't
upgrade a twig to a two-dimensional twig
so it's nice to comment that upgrading a
puzzle purely for aesthetic things to
set it as a nice puzzle
also had mathematical consequences i've
got to put a random candle and a random
cut on a two-dimensional surface and
then suddenly it's less obvious to me
how you put
a candle or a cut on a two-dimensional
thing before i had many panics about
this so i'll just run a simulation
rather than trying to solve it on a
two-dimensional cake so i got a georgia
profile to do a square cake it was
easier to draw before you criticize my
model in hindsight i'm going to mention
very carefully how i chose where the
random things go but i didn't think hard
about it at the start i just picked a
random x coordinate a random y
coordinate for each of the candles and
for the cut i picked a random x and y
and a random angle
that's definitely a random cut and i was
fine with that and i ran my simulation
uh which i haven't i haven't made it
look particularly pretty but if i do run
it again
it ends up
converging to about a third again and i
was like well what's really nice about
the one dimension i wanted upgrade so
two dimensional one and cakes work and
this is this is just above a third at
the moment but it's point three
something fine and i went and did a talk
about this at math jam annual weekend
and everyone was nice about it we had
nice conversations and in the back of my
head i was like this is a little
mathematical
bug saying
are you sure you know what you mean by
random when you're in not just
a uniform distribution
and i wasn't sure and i didn't think
about it because i was kind of naively
lulled into a four-cent security because
the number was what i wanted
but it turns out
there are other ways to randomly assign
a cut and if this is sounding familiar
with something i've alluded to earlier
your conversation with grant about
bertrand's paradox was precisely about
pick a random cut or chord on a circle
so forget the square cake uh which we
could go and do the model with again but
let's upgrade to a real cake definitely
a circle and i've got to put the candles
on at random and actually i'm happy
enough that choosing a place for these
to go at random is actually doable
although you can do it in several
methods and it's not obvious which one's
best let's just spray points on like i
did before random x and random y
coordinate and if they're outside the
circle reject them so we'll get a random
point on the cake and that's a good way
of uniformly spreading the points out
but it's the cut that's a problem
because what we're doing is randomly
choosing a chord pick two random end
points like this point and this point
that would define that cut because any
chord is defined by the two endpoints
alternatively though you could pick a
random point in the circle a bit like i
did with a candle like this one
and say that's the midpoint of a chord
and any point uniquely defines a chord
in that way but it's a different
distribution of cuts and this is where
you start getting into deep water the
nature of random is not as simple as you
want it to be don't watch grant's video
for a big discussion about it but what i
did do was simulate the cake and candles
cut problem with uh round cakes and
several different choices of how to do
random chord i really enjoyed the
conversation you had with grant because
you were annoyed that it wasn't well
defined
and
i think mathematicians do have that
sense of annoyance you want things to be
neat but probability questions are often
more philosophical than we want them to
be so this is a video of me choosing the
two endpoints on the circumference and
the orange trace is where the chords
gone i don't know why i picked this
color scheme but i liked it and i ended
up just mesmerized by the image the
thing is the distribution is is maybe
not what you expected is kind of
clustering towards the edges and the
middle is slightly less sparse but it is
quite uniform so maybe this is arguably
a good way of getting uniform cuts but
there's another way of choosing the cut
it's not a third it's actually settling
down to be about 0.16 that was after 10
000 attempts so i believe this
if you choose a cut by this method
which if we're gonna do it for real life
the real context would be like we'd put
a spinner
we'd do a couple of spinners in the
middle and wherever it pointed to we
mark an end point and we cut there
it looks like we get about 0.16 of the
time we'd get
a candle on each piece
and that's not a third it's not even
close which kind of upsets me
uh
yeah it's almost a half of a third it's
almost a half of a third um
is it near to an eighth as well but this
is why the monte carlo methods and the
simulations don't give you that sort of
theoretical they confirm theory quite
nicely but this time it means my
theoretical thing has just not matured
enough to sort it out and if you run
different simulations here are just the
pictures of what happens if you choose
the cuts in different ways
so this cut is where you choose a random
midpoint for the chord and you see it
hardly ever cuts or just less often cuts
near the middle and that's a good reason
why we're getting different
probabilities this one ends up being
settling down to about 0.19 this one
over here is choosing a random radial
point so that's choosing some distance
along a radius and there's some angle
around the center to go and using that
as the midpoint different distribution
again and this one's doing what i did on
my naive version of the square a random
point and random angle adding more
randomness this one ends up to be 0.3
close to a third but not close enough
this one ends up being 0.325
my main conclusion of this is that i
don't know what's going on uh and it's
sometimes nice to be mystified as a
mathematician and realize that
the real world of random distributions
in two dimensions and in situations like
grant discusses in this video is more
complicated than you want it to be we
need to be careful about probability i
think in summary though what i liked
about this problem is that we took a
basic
twig turned it into a cake problem
there's a nice lesson about solving
things in two ways but there's also
deeper water and you get a glimpse of
how mathematicians work they start with
a simple problem and you realize that
you tweak one part of the model and
things get more complicated hey that's
where we get our fun out as
mathematicians it wouldn't be super hard
for one to do the mathematics of what
the probabilities are once you decide
your definition
correct uh i mean you haven't done it i
just haven't done it yeah
but the problem is which definition is
truly random yeah and that's the
alarming thing it feels like surely that
one of these is better but it's not
clear that it is you need to be precise
about how you're modeling the real world
because the real world is complicated
what's your what's your personal
preference for what counts as the truly
random cut of the cake let me answer
that by the pictures uh if you look at
these it doesn't feel like this is
distributing cuts fairly
maybe what we call uniformly it feels
like a random method that's the random
midpoint um this one
they're subtly different this one is
clustering towards the edges a little
bit but not as much as this one whereas
this one feels like it's colored in the
circle and that was me picking a random
point by some method and a random angle
and maybe that double random application
makes it look more uniform
it also backs me up and says it's
roughly a third
but i'm really aware you're saying
that's the correct one because it's
tempting to you want to believe the
answers that you think are consistent
and there's no guarantee
the reality works like that
and who's to say that when you cut a
cake randomly into all the cuts there
wouldn't be like
a little hole in the middle like of
and actually this is where probability
questions but maybe the knife would
touch the middle less often when you it
depends how you're going to randomly cut
it if you've got without briefing people
on the complexities here you just gave
them a knife and a cake and said right i
wanted to repeatedly cut it at random
how would they do it
i
i think they'd hold it from one side and
then just like hack at it and we know
actually that it's not going to be
random because it's all going to come
from probably this end point and we're
going to be spinning around here
if they thought about it maybe they'd do
the double spinner approach and pick two
end points but that feels like a lot of
work or you get a what do they call it a
lazy susan put the cake on it spin that
round stop it and then go
is it if this was cranked up to about 90
miles an hour it would be a more random
demonstration of picking a random angle
to cut so i close my eyes and wait until
i have no idea where the candles are all
right yeah how long are we waiting
hang on i'll do an old return you
haven't seen as well just to random up a
bit more all right let's see here we go
the lengths we go to for maths go ahead
if i slice this down on miss and just
break your turn table how's that gonna
slice gently make sure you hit the cake
say when when
we're done yep ah we're between the
candles you did it what are the chances
don't answer that just only just yeah
the the point candle model was nearly
not sufficient
now ben's got a deep video and i mean
really deep about how he visualized and
programmed some of this stuff on his own
channel
if you'd like to check it out well
there'll be links on the screen down in
the description all the usual places
and you might like to reflect on what it
is
but i really like this is i just really
like the way this looks um to be honest
this is what i was going for in the
entire video here